andrew is with us in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Andrew how are you Dave how
are you doing better than I deserve
what's up I just had a question I wanted
to ask you I'm currently a graduate
student and I'm trying to learn for all
the baby steps and I'm learning with
graduate school I'm trying to learn how
to which one should I prioritize between
graduate school my previous debt
requirement and just having fun okay
retirements not on the table until your
debt free don't worry about that that's
what we call baby step for fun is is
somehow been mislabeled
that it has to cost money I've heard of
people having fun without spending money
I'm not sure why fun has to cost that's
an illusion sold to you by someone so do
you spend some money on fun sure sure
absolutely a reasonable amount but let's
just use an example let's pretend that
you spend so much money on fun that you
can't pay for graduate school and you
build up a bunch of student loan debt
which effectively means you borrowed
money on student loans to have fun yeah
that would not be wise right right so I
mean we're not got we're nice a no
there's no fun but being a student loan
that's no fun either so that so can you
pay cash for graduate school and just
finish as goal one I can yeah okay let's
do that
that's goal one and if we don't pay off
any debt and we don't start retirement
goal one is go no further in debt
because the first step of getting out of
debt is to stop borrowing more that's
step one okay so let's start with that
one and then let's sprinkle a little fun
on right after that a little fun not
trips to Europe okay well you have debt
and then if you know how much is that
how much money do you need to finish
grad school probably about 25 okay okay
and what is your sources of income right
now are you working yeah I work
basically three jobs yeah okay for grad
school so $25,000 in you graduate when
2020
may the I I think that summer of twenty
twenty twenty four months then yeah okay
and you so you need twenty five thousand
and twenty four months you ever take
correct all right and what are you
making a year I make about thirty eight
okay and so can you do the twenty can
you can you cash flow this if you got
another source of money without
borrowing it yeah I can cash flow it
okay all right and what are you studying
mental health cowboy okay so you're
gonna get a master's in counseling
correct and then you'll sit for your
boards and you're going into the
counseling industry counseling world
correct okay good good for you alright
and how much debt do you have already
about eighteen okay is that student
loans only yeah that's food that long
okay and they don't activate till you
graduate correct okay so we're just
gonna let them set good alright so goal
one is graduate debt-free until you have
$25,000 cash sitting in your savings
account I would do only inexpensive fun
and I would pay nothing on debt and save
nothing for the future because job one
is add no more debt and let's graduate
debt-free now let's pretend something
weird happened and you had twenty five
thousand dollars in the bank by January
that's not gonna happen unless something
in this story changes but if it did
let's just say that happened this coming
January so you got eighteen months and
you got the money already done right
right then you can increase your fund
budget a little bit right and then you
could even start thinking about maybe
paying off the eighteen thousand right
right and as soon as that's done then
we're gonna build an emergency fund and
then we're going to move on into
retirement savings you're going to do
your retirement savings after you
graduate probably which is fine fine
just start putting fifteen percent of
your income away and you're debt-free
when you graduate that'd be a great goal
but go one stick with that goal no
matter what it takes no matter what you
have to do that is legal and moral
borrow no more
more money and graduate with no more
harm you can't get out of a hole while
you're digging out the bottom step one
to paying off debt is not borrow anymore
and that is a big step for a lot of
people so I would take up your credit
cards time for a plus SEC to me
plastic surgery is in your life that
kind of stuff right so that that's what
we're doing so good job man good job
stay on it stay on it finish it up
finish that degree cuz it's gonna be a
good field it'll be a rewarding field
for you